[Musique]
35 degrés à l'ombre
c'est une température de vacances aussi
la vie à paris s'était notablement
engourdi pour prendre un rythme estival
à l'heure du premier rush vers les
plages et la montagne
pendant ce temps les gars étaient
littéralement assiégé 200000 parisien
ils sont partis en trois jours
[Musique]
à l'occasion de ces départs le train
auto couchette s'est intégré un peu plus
à la tradition des vacances la sncf a
mis en service sur la ligne paris
biarritz un nouveau train d'automobiles
accompagné qui prend en charge les
véhicules en même temps que les
voyageurs une solution originale sans
aucun doute qui permet tout en gardant
pour ainsi dire sa voiture sous la main
d'oublier les soucis de là
[Musique]
dans le même temps le chemin de la côte
d'azur s'est raccourcie par l'ouverture
dans sa totalité de l'autoroute estérel
côte d'azur qui est la première
autoroute française à péage il convient
de noter que sa construction qui a duré
cinq ans a coûté 22 milliards d'anciens
francs
désormais grâce à ses 63 km d'autoroutes
en état pour ce parcours moitié moins de
temps gain appréciable pour les
vacanciers pressé d'arriver à la mer et
ils le sont toujours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]